hi this is Sal Khan founder of the Khan
Academy and I just wanted to announce
our second annual Talent Search as you
may know Khan Academy were a
not-for-profit with a mission of a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and part of that is creating
the content that can reach students from
kindergarten all the way through early
college and all of the core academic
subjects and that content is videos it's
articles and exercises and the reason
why we do the Talent Search is we're
looking for folks who can really connect
with students on those subjects and so
this year we're doing the Talent Search
again and we're especially looking at
core academic subjects that aren't on
Khan Academy already or we're kind of
cutting we does not already have a
significant offering I encourage you to
go to the Talent Search website to get a
little bit more detail there you know
this is a really exciting thing for us
there are going to be prizes for the
finalists but more importantly it's a
way for us to foster more people getting
involved with content creation which I
think all of you will enjoy and for a
way for us to discover new talent and
last year out of the the finalists to
have actually had content creation
contracts with Khan Academy including
grant and David hi everyone my name is
grant Sanderson I was one of the Talent
Search winners from last year I now make
multivariable calculus videos and some
other content for Khan Academy and I
just have to say as someone who cares
about reaching students and who cares
about addressing needs like that I can't
imagine a better place to be than here
and that's not just because you can
reach a lot of people but what the Khan
Academy folk around here care about is
just genuinely helping students so I am
the grammar fellow at Khan Academy I am
very passionate about grammar and I'm
curious to know what you're excited
about what are your big passions what do
you love to think about what do you love
to tell people about what do people like
learning from you is it macroeconomics
is it business theory is it psychology
whatever it is whatever your passion is
put it into a video and send it to us so
please make your videos have fun with
them think about how you can connect
with the world and send us your
submissions bye
August first